[Music]
michael's gonna start us off in iowa hey
michael how are you
wonderful how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so my question is as
you're helping people in their financial
journey and becoming debt free
when you get to that point that you're
financially free from any payments
and you have
children that are in the house i
understand that
you know
instilling the values that
you
you know don't use debt in your everyday
life and
you know
when you get to that point and you're
still having you know younger kids at
home
how do you
[Music]
how did you do it with your children
so that way you know as they
moved out of the house
they weren't
feeling entitled or
you know oh you know mom and dad have
money so
you know i can
basically use it's a great question
what they have so so how do you keep
becoming from becoming wealthy and it's
screwing up your kids
exactly like entitlement entitlement is
arrogance
it's i'm do something that i didn't earn
okay
you could you can you can fix that with
kids regardless of the amount of money
in your house
okay so ramsey kids growing up um were
uh entitlement was not something we
allowed and self-centered
self-centeredness was not something we
allowed and they're very similar
so a couple of things we did and i'm
gonna send you a copy of the number one
bestseller rachel and i did together
called smart money smart kids uh and so
there's a couple of items uh let's start
with a very uh
philosophical highbrow thing
um contentment
is almost never around entitled people
contentment comes
from
gratitude
i'm thankful
lord thank you for what i have
and it helps you to be content in what
you have and so our children it was not
an option we trained them in their
gratitude muscle
thank you
please
yes sir
no sir yes ma'am no ma'am we're from the
south
you're gonna have you're gonna have
manners and you're going to
uh you're not going to
allow someone to
impose themselves across your boundaries
or do something evil or wrong to you
that's not what we're saying but thank
you
i'm sorry
verbal generosity
sets the table for the rest of this
discussion
and then the rest of the discussion and
it's all age-appropriate
okay but it does melt to grandpa's heart
when my two-year-old or
three-year-old that's barely talking is
thank you papa
or maybe you can't even maybe it wasn't
even enunciated that well right
so you know some baby talk version right
but thank you papa
it changes my whole life when that
happens right when i watch that because
that's gratitude and gratitude is what's
missing in entitled people
and so um
once you do that then we taught our kids
to do four basic things in the money
thing that were character issues we
built their muscle age appropriately
number one they learned to work
you don't have an option if you're a
ramsay you're going to work now we
didn't send three-year-olds to the salt
mines
okay it's age-appropriate
but when you're 16 and you're exhausted
because you've been in the backyard with
your old man cutting trees or cleaning
the furniture or whatever all day long
oh crimea river
your butt's going to be out there in the
sun sweating like your old man doing
this stuff work physical labor is good
work that is mental that you're mentally
and emotionally exhausted when you're
through with there is dignity in work
there is no dignity and sloth
and so age appropriately intense
intensity increasing with age you had to
work if you're ramsey because that's
where money comes from
it doesn't come from the government i'm
sorry joe biden it doesn't come from you
i'm sorry donald trump it doesn't come
from you none of you have ever sent me
any of my any money except some of you
sent some of my money back to me
but none of you sent me any money that
wasn't already mine in the first place
because i'd already sent you more than
that
and so that's how that works now once
you learn to work then we had three
other muscles we need to build and
that's the muscle of generosity and
that's not only holding the door and
saying thank you and please
and putting the dishes in the dishwasher
for your mama because you say i love you
that way but the the generosity is also
you give money away
age appropriately oddly enough you don't
have to teach young children that they
will try to give too much away
they are much more generous than we
selfish adults are number two uh they
need to learn to um
uh give save they need to save money
build a savings muscle learn to set a
goal learn to work towards a goal and
then number three spend wise spending
and people that can do all four of those
things when they leave home at 18 don't
ever move back into your basement
they work they save they give they spend
they're grateful they say please and
thank you and they mean it and they know
the axis of the world does not run
through the top of their entitled little
head and they don't end up becoming
activists
they actually get a job and produce
something for the culture
that's right
i i would just add one thing michael and
i'm in the middle of it right now with
three teams and uh i i think we as
parents need to let our kids struggle
more and what i mean by that is put them
in a place where they must struggle and
then allow the struggle whether that be
learning an instrument
uh or a new job right because when
you're taking on a job with the first
time at 15 that's why you got one in
football practice yes sir that's true i
think i think whether it's a sport or it
is some type of extracurricular activity
i interviewed malcolm gladwell about
this many many years ago one of the
great thinkers on the planet and he
essentially said this and what happens
is when we as parents
try to keep our kids from a place of
struggle then what happens is is they
begin to expect benefit or success
instead of appreciate it and it's much
like dave just said on the working part
but you know entitlement to me is when i
expect something not appreciate
something and struggle when you grow up
in a household like that or a household
like i grew up in or you grew up in we
got triggered on something
there were no safe places no
no in fact we did actually
your butt was about to go to work
well you know to your point i would
never dream of getting triggered with my
dad no because i'm gonna tell you what
would have been triggered
because i could hear the leather belt
whistling through the belt loops as he
pulled it off
i'm talking about it
if you have a problem with something you
don't expect someone else to fix it or
to keep you safe yeah when you when you
survive struggle right and so that's the
thing but when you actually taste it and
feel it you go wait a second i
appreciate it when you have overcome
obstacles it builds character builds
muscle it builds confidence it builds
dignity
when that when no one has overcome a
struggle there's no dignity in their
life
hang on we'll send you a copy of smart
money smart kids and get you started on
that that's a great question thanks for
letting us get up on a soapbox